I'm so sorry everybody sorry for the
delay there's so much that's happening
on this show you just won't even believe
the kind of technological wizardry we
have to pull off to get this thing up
and running as you can tell by the title
screen we're gonna be talking about
experimental typography today it's from
our zoom class in attendance here we
noticed a little drop off this week the
last week week seven of the experimental
typography but joining us in studio
safely safely as safe as we can is no
konoka how are you doing
no cause muted oh there you go I am
needed you know you're fine oh hi
everyone today's experimental as you can
see we're experimenting and we're
discovering new things thank you for
having me here today
I'm really excited about today's show
and forgive me if I'm looking at a bunch
of different places oh god I've got a
camera okay the reason why we're doing
it the way we're doing it today is
because I think one of your secret
genius gifts is to be able to work hands
on to put your hands onto things and so
she's come into the studio because we
have a lot more camera and equipment
here of course is added some complexity
to our set up but I think you guys are
in for a real treat now if you're just
joining us for the first time ever on
this series of typography critiques
I'm Christo and joining me is Milka
Brooklyn and she's an art center
professor our Center graduate with a
master's degree in design she's taught
for over 15 years and one of the lead
designers over at Snap and she also
designed the parents company's logo so
that's really cool so MOCA I know and
we'll mention it later on to you and I
have something cooking up it's not quite
fully formed yet but we want to invite
you especially during this time when
you're available to do one-on-one
critiquing with a small group so very
limited class size it's just like the
way we learn typography in school so I'm
excited to talk about that okay let's
just jump right into it should we shall
we thank you okay let's go and where is
my desktop there it is
all right so we got a bunch of really
interesting submissions this week so I'm
gonna zoom out real quick so you guys
can see lower looking at I'm gonna zoom
in now every week we make some
adjustments in terms of how we do these
critiques we spend too much time on just
a few or we spend not enough time on too
many so today it's the last time so I'm
hoping that I get it right this time
all right everybody so here we are I'm
gonna dive in here so I'm looking at
these layouts and we have a wide range
of things from photographic explorations
some faux 3d 2d repetition moving
typography all over so I'm very excited
but I thought you know what are some of
the principles things that we should
think about before we get into all of
those stuff so as the names implies
experimental we want you to push the
boundaries we want you to have fun show
your passion and energy and excitement
for this stuff so there's things that we
can do you can take two-dimensional type
and you can make it three-dimensional
you can do this by actually building
physical forms you can take type and
print out on clear acetate sheets and
you can bend it and manipulate it that
way
that's kind of cool you can obviously
add textures to things which we touched
on last week so if you haven't seen that
go back to last week and check it out
you can de-stress the type meaning you
can give it some patina you can age it
you can tear it apart I have some tricks
I can share with you as well you can
also manipulate the letter forms you
know the type once you converted to
outlines you can push and pull the
different anchor points and maybe create
something very expressive more painterly
you could use photography introduce a
whole brand new element with depth of
field and projecting type onto surfaces
and capturing it that way so it's not
done on the computer anymore and you can
play around with figure-ground and big
you 'ti which is a fancy way of saying
we're not quite sure what's on top so I
want to show you an example that and I
have more examples from my deck which
I'll show you as well okay so let's look
here so when I talk about figure ground
ambiguity we assume we assume where's my
type there it is
selected for some reason okay we're off
to a great start
let me grab this type all right what the
heck is going on
cut face in front oh I know why I made
this type white I'm black that's why I
couldn't see it alright so when we look
at a white page like this I drop type in
it looks very clear to us what's on the
foreground and what's in the background
and you would say like the thing that's
most complex the letters are a and Z for
a resonate is on the foreground and it's
on a white background but when we start
to mix this around it creates this
really cool just all thing that's
happening where it vibrates on the page
and I'll show you what I mean with that
so here it looks very clearly to me that
it's black on white until you start to
look at the R and E and then it looks
like the white is on top of the black
and depending on how we push and pull
these elements in a very two-dimensional
way we're getting achieve this ambiguity
between what's in the foreground and
what's in the background you also can
see here and that this halftone pattern
behind the journal fur graphic design is
blocked out a little bit by this white
box that I've highlighted here so now
that allows the white to sit on top of
the black but then the black of the
journal for graphic design sits on top
of that so you can create a lot of
dimensionality that way okay I'm gonna
stop the share and switch over my deck
here and my deck is on this channel here
so we're going to talk about
experimental typography I want to show
you more examples to kind of set the
stage for what we're gonna do today so
here's some examples this one this first
set is from Chris Ashworth who's been on
the channel before if you haven't seen
that episode go check it out and he does
some really amazing compositions he's a
big fan of electro set rub down
lettering which you can't get anymore
because he stopped making that a while
back but pre-computer predestination
that was the best way for you to quickly
mock up something so he has a huge
collection of press down lettering and
you can see these compositions that
he'll make they're tiny and he'll
include things like bar codes black
gaffing tape or artist tape and and mix
it in with other materials like the
brownish color of them like masking tape
and tearing it out
really beautiful compositions and using
halftone patterns they're quite amazing
so if you haven't seen his work yet go
on Instagram check them out at Ashworth
Chris and next up oh I'm sorry and he
also did a stint on ray gun and the
reason why I got to confuse is because
of the next person I'm gonna focus on so
he took over for ray gun magazine as the
creative director after David Carson had
left so the next person that you're
gonna need to be aware of that is really
one of the forefathers of modern
experimental typography is David Carson
and this is a mad a bit Carson's work
from his commercial campaign for Pepsi I
think when advertising was really bold
and brave and doing crazy interesting
things and working with designers and
from the book the end of print here's
another spread by the way David Carson
just FYI
as you made many of you guys know he
didn't have a formal design training it
was a sociology professor and because
his passion was typography and art and
design he went for it and he has some
really cool stories about when he
started to break the rules how it was
pushed against him but then the magazine
really took it and that's what took the
magazine to another level mm-hmm have
you read his full biography I'm just
curious
well you put me on the spot I save you
I'll save you there is nice I know I
know
of course he you know we're in touch
with him he's an environment but through
a lot of research and studies I know to
some extent but when you say full
biography please expand on that yeah
because I actually and I may have
mistakenly read this but I read that he
Ashton went to Basel Switzerland to
studies typography so I don't want to
stir up the controversy but there's this
creation creation mythology like the the
story of David Carson's much more
interesting when you say he's a
sociology professor or student major and
he's never studied design under anybody
but it actually may not be true and
that's okay i he didn't
or maybe this is the way it was fun and
there's a lot of those kinds of things
that go going goes on when you build
your personal brand but if I do that
I'll ask him I thought I read that he
did attend Basel Switzerland to study
pipe for a little time no I pulled it
out of the hat of his armpit or whatever
like this amazing designer but I also
want to do for the UM I want to share
with you guys this book that I have and
I'm using my overhead camera let me push
just a little bit out of the way this is
his latest book here it and it's kind of
him transitioning from being a graphic
designer
to being more of a fine artist and you
can even see her in a very true spirit
of David Carson this book does not have
the binding on it the back cover and
it's left open here just so you can see
how the book is actually constructed and
you can see these signatures which I
think are 16 pages sewn together and
glued on the back and it's pretty cool
because I also allows you to open it up
without fear of ripping binding and it's
really neat because I think he's moved
into this phase in his life in his
career where he's doing a lot more
collage work and I wanted to share that
with you because I think some of our
students that are enrolled in the class
or perhaps you're curious about
typography you could start to look at
this and say wow maybe I have really
fully explored everything that there is
to explore yet and I think that's the
theme of today's show which is to really
push you out of your comfort zone like
look at this typography it's quite
exquisite for me and Milka while we're
looking at David Carson's work here just
to kind of whet everybody's appetite on
this is so beautiful to me yeah yeah
yeah you can see that these letter forms
are cut and because it's cut and paste
and collage together you have the
physical properties of the page itself
and limitations and constraints within
that space and how you're able to be
creative around that and I I think I
also bought this either a Knicks are
approaching or a self-published thing
and I look for these kinds of books yeah
yeah it's an awesome designer a while
back I was looking at his lighthouse and
this was like when I was still in school
and I would lay tracing paper over a
very chaotic page and see if I can
deconstruct what's going on and would
tape pen and
and paper I would draw all over it and
lo and behold there actually is a very
strong grid element underneath all of it
and it looks haphazard it looks random
it looks totally chaotic but the grid is
very much there and alive underneath the
swirl because a lot of people try this
kind of work and it's terrible but
that's what we're talking about when you
learn the rules then you can go break
the rules and it becomes very intuitive
it's inside you so you're you don't need
a ruler or a measuring cup to measure it
for you you know it inside your head and
it the work speaks back to you to know
how much how far to go and where not to
go
look at this song the guys or is it let
me try and get it on the shop give it a
shot here that's really cool to me just
a little bit of typography with an image
treated as a duotone or monotone image
they're really cool I'm not gonna go
through the whole book but there's some
really beautiful stuff in there mostly
I'm just showing off my camera setup
guys yes or no okay let's get back to it
so this is David Carson's book I believe
you could probably still get it I know
there's only so many that were printed
that's the cover it's about that thick
really cool came back to my camera here
that would be a very nice gift people
who don't have the copy yet yes
after today so noka has referred to
their next design legend wolfgang fine
guard and if you look at this work it
was done quite some time ago but it's a
really beautiful amazing work and again
you can still see that the edges of the
paper because I think phototypesetting
was still a thing back then and you can
see how things were put together I love
seeing that kind of stuff and I like
seeing a neutral ground the paper itself
has this dark grayish green color and
then you could have something that is
darker the black typography and
something that's lighter the reverse
knocked out white type on the bottom
lower third area so some really
beautiful if you want to say something
okay no I'm enjoying this okay thank you
for sharing here's a little bit more of
Wolfgang's work here amazing beautiful
compositions here now I know you're
looking at this and
I'm gonna give some of you guys a hard
time you started to introduce photo
elements which I didn't want you to do
Wolfgang Stein in his class he's a
master how dare I would critique or say
anything about his work so I'm not going
to but for what you guys are doing I
wanted you stick to graphics lines rules
shapes and type so that you can master
that and not delve right into all this
photography and illustration stuff okay
next up is odor man is actually that
gives me an idea maybe we could expand
into the next class where they can use
color and they can use images with
typography because those will be other
parameters to add on absolutely and I do
for judgment to the teacher of course
so imagine EC odor Mattson t see the
duel here just oh this implicit e of the
screen poster I just love it so much
that it feels very Swiss to me that
there's three boxes perfectly square but
because it's cropped and bleeding off
the right edge and then a whole lot of
negative space on the left side yeah so
beautiful and then using is this called
kanji like a Japanese letter form but a
Helvetica version of it and it looks so
beautiful too and you have this centered
layout with this asymmetry of the
typography on the left-hand side and
it's really detailed and fine you'll
notice on a lot of Instagram accounts
they have a big image and they have this
little mouse type this little detail
type it's for that reason to add
contrast you're not supposed to read all
that little type on Instagram so they're
borrowing the same principles of poster
design and applying it to instagrams
here's a couple more layouts there oh
really
super beautiful amazing okay so there's
also Joseph Milla Brockman which some of
you guys have been referencing as well
and that's been mentioned quite a bit so
his use of rules and lines and actually
when I was looking and deconstructing
his work those of you guys that have
taken the course I've seen the way that
these things are devised it's very
mathematical and it's really beautiful
relying on the golden circle or the
golden means and using those proportions
it's really beautiful work so these
these little rectangles that you see on
this black and white poster they're not
just arbitrarily pay placing who's
following a very strict
great structure and that's why it looks
so good it's so dynamic and this is the
one and the poster on the left-hand side
here with the circles going in that I
constructed so you can see like how did
that how did those sizes and the
placement of those circles how did it
come to happen what was going on there
[Laughter]
okay we're back okay all right so
there's this other poster here that just
means sign for I believe it's for a film
festival or something and it's the
overlapping of typography just want to
share that with you and there's Cal arts
professor and chair at Edward fella
he does something really super amazing
he goes around all over the world and
takes Polaroids of interesting
typography and he either scans it in or
redraws it and comes up with these super
lyrical expressive pieces of typography
by the way he's still alive you guys so
if you want to take advantage of getting
to know him reach out to him yes and
when you see the work that comes out of
the Cal art students it seems like it's
very heavily influenced by their
professors and their thinking so if
there was any kind of rivalry between
Cal arts and Art Center it would be that
Cal arts sort of super expressive fun
lyrical typography Art Center is much
more gridded functional it maybe even
corporate sometimes so different schools
of thought now there's a lot of other
typography that I'm inspired by and I
wanted to share with you kind of just
spark your imagination to get your
creative juices flowing so I don't know
who the individual designers are artists
are behind these pieces but I have a
collection here I just wanted to share
with you and I wanted to talk about them
a little bit so the one on the left of
the bang what milk and I were talking
about for quite some time is to have one
focal point something big and then let
everything else be really quiet against
that and what I like in that red
typography is you know upper left-hand
corner is it's not at the same angle
it's just kind of delicately placed on
top at a different angle and it works
and then there's this one little element
to the
I think what Milko would talk talk about
the satellites and pushing things and
activating the whole page that thing
angers in the bottom right corner I'm
not gonna go and deconstruct every
single print and poster that I'm showing
showing sharing with you today but I
just want to point out some things in
case you're like I ran out of ideas why
am I even on this topic is because we
saw a big drop-off in terms of who was
posting work maybe you felt intimidated
I heard right before we went on air all
this week was really really hard well it
just takes a little time and
consideration and thought into getting
something like this I also like this
poster on the far right here which it
feels like they printed that normally
and then they folded it and tucked parts
of the poster underneath itself and
created a little bit of a cash shadow
and when I go to arts center they have
exhibitions like this and they take the
paper and then they fold it and they
mount it on the wall as a dimensional
poster so it's not a 2d plane anymore it
becomes a three-dimensional thing and
it's able to cache shadows so something
for you to think about there and then
there's posters like this using simple
circles and in squares and reversing
knocking things out and adding some
really beautiful typography in there I
also like this show poster where they
have the letter forms which all capitals
not that interesting to look at but they
they screen it back they knock down the
opacity in certain parts of it then it
makes it feel like it's hieroglyphic in
nature so more poster work some random
spacing for the monochrome poster there
with the camera in the background this
poster works just fine without that
camera so if you're thinking that the
camera is the thing that makes it it's
not the designer makes it makes these
decisions and knows that they need
something dark and black up there but it
could have been in just a simple shape
and just to prove that here are more
posters for me to look at some of these
were from Paula Scher the taxi one and
the one on the far right I really wanted
to show you this set of posters and
these were done for a campaign with Nike
and LeBron James and I think was called
witness LA or witness and different
cities if you can do if you can command
typography
and be able to lay out a page like this
you probably have a job somewhere
already lined up for you because I think
people in advertising look at this and
say wow this is really good somebody has
to know what they're doing and so I hope
that this sparks something inside of you
to say like all you have to do I mean I
don't want to diminish it is all you
have to do is to learn how to use type
how to control space and make it
interesting while still having it be
legible and you'll be a sought-after
commodity I thought these were really
cool so wood block lettering they're
from doing some letterpress fitting the
letter forms in there into these little
boxes and having some of the texture
come through the gradient type adds a
lot of dimensionality it makes the type
appear as if you are bending out from
the page from the left edge towards the
center and it's really cool it kind of a
neat optical illusion there and getting
into more experimental stuff here
collage type collage type yes I also
love this poster right here in the
middle oh really neat very simple and
you guys have taken type before and have
put it on a plane but adding a little
bit of a lighting effect to it maybe
this fits into the photographic one
where you're using you to Photoshop or
something else to manipulate it or an
illustrator but even the one on the on
the right here with just simple dots
adding texture usually you know for the
type directors club they they have some
really interesting posters they have to
to celebrate typography so if they're
bad at it not a very credible
organization but some other ideas here
on the far right of course we're
introducing an additional element of
color but I mean you guys can imagine
that is gray and it'll still work we're
almost done here and if you were running
out of ideas
there's just designer I know if you go
to this website called Milka dot design
you can actually see the work of some of
her students and I pulled a few of them
they're the kind of small low res but
there are a few here that can inspire
your thinking so Milko do you want to
talk about these oh my god they're so
yummy and seductive aren't they yeah I
want to say that experimental takes it's
not like it happens it could but it's
something that cooks over a layer and
there as you go through each process and
I can show you a few samples that I
brought here to show you but this one do
you see my arrow know that the top left
one the top left one is done on
transparency and then it's put into the
water you know a glass jar of water and
then photographed as simple as that the
one in the middle I think they used
water and ice and the one on the right
which I really love it's basically just
cut and then have some light shine
behind it and we can show you some of
that as well moving to the bottom left
that's just collage all type collage
just cut and paste can't paste and the
one in the below app bottom middle my
favorite it's just basically sewing
taking a needle and thread and just
sewing across the paper and then the one
on the far bottom-right what is that one
I think that one's also done with water
and ice because you'll be surprised how
fluid you can get your materials to
become by using different materials such
as water such as eyes such as I want to
say heat but be careful with that you
can take you can take your piece and
freeze it and then take it out and then
hammer it and take a picture of it yeah
there's other tricks that you guys can
do as well you can use your inkjet
printer and print onto transparencies
and then either squirt it with water or
some kind of chemical cleaner as
something that's household so nothing
nothing corrosive nothing that's gonna
burn your face or eyes
but and then you'll see that the ink
starts to melt and bleed and come free
of the acetate backer that's on it so
those are a lot of different things that
you can do when Milka talked about Heat
yes you can burn you could destroy tie
lots of different things you can do but
of course use good judgment there use
common sense all right Kyle Cooper is
another artist a good example who uses a
lot of this technique that just Chris
mentioned yeah okay so I have another
book here I want to share everything we
put Mike out of the way here boom this
book here yeah this is amazing so one of
my instructors was a part of this
collective called 8vo and they designed
this magazine called octavo and it was a
magazine designed to chronicle and to
spotlight beautiful typography so this
book was a Kickstarter project that I
backed a while ago probably two or three
years ago and it's just beautiful so
this is a red slipcover and that's
transparent it's it's over they need oil
book it's really amazing exquisitely
produced printed of course the power of
good design look how powerful this is
I'm trying not to read my book as I
showed you it here so gorgeous so
seductive yeah this is kind of mylar
silver paper and I'm going to get into
it so the the really cool thing about
the book is these are all amazing
designers all in their own right and
they came together to design and talk
about typography so this is forwarded by
Simon Johnston who's my professor and I
believe Milka you had him too right
oh yes yes we both had Simon Johnson and
in fact Simon Johnson was the student of
Wolfgang
well Wolfgang's you yeah one girl
Wolfgang thank you Wolfgang weingartz
and he was the student of wolf Wolfgang
one guard and so we're the grandchildren
yes yes and in here in the book it says
that our table occurred right at the
cusp of the digital revolution so you're
gonna see some things that bleed over
from digital typesetting and traditional
phototypesetting and pasted up so it's
really really just beautiful
so this is I believe a yellow paper that
they printed on top ah and I'm gonna
just skip forward to some of the design
here because there's some interviews
there we got
cover by cover spread by spread
beautiful see this type as texture here
using transparencies just using rules
here the bold versus the thin using the
line to show you the column width to
kind of reinforce that so these are all
the spreads and then I'm gonna move a
little faster here so you guys see this
and so when you guys go back and look at
your assignment from week one to now
revisit it think about what you could
have done differently and do it again
one thing that we weren't able to do in
this class via this online format that
we're in right now is to be able to go
back and say okay you're supposed to do
ten layouts and the next week you're
supposed to refine five of last week's
work and add additional ten of this
week's work so it was it can get pretty
heavy but through this rigor this
repetition you start to learn how to
design how to use typography and I think
a lot of you and I hope you can feel
this when I say this and I say this very
sincerely I've grown a lot in the short
few weeks that we spent together yes hi
great these were very rigorous
assignments and they're gonna pay off so
well some I know geeking out here
because I just love this kind of stuff
but to find a book like this where every
single page you can just sit there and
examine and study these few lines here
and then this breaks it but then they
knock out a few things to kind of draw
your attention to that really beautiful
stuff hmm okay let me fast forward here
a little bit look at this stuff guys
so we said mental you don't necessarily
have to go start melting type and
freezing it and burning it yes
and and manipulate it so that you get
some really interesting layouts and
negative space all right I'm gonna keep
going here I'm going kind of fast here
there's one in here that had these
gradients I wanted to show you some of
you who can't get this book who can't
afford this book and also because the
book is I think sold out already out of
print and we're kind of done you get
step by step freeze-frame these and
maybe stop and look at them train
schedules license plates now I know why
Simon gave this assignment to design a
license plate it makes sense and the
train schedule which is one of the
assignments that we had to do it's right
huh what what assignments did you get
from aside from Simon I had hierarchy of
typography and I had a couple of other
corporate courses with him yeah look at
this oh that is that's QuarkXPress era
it is but I think this is pre digital
revolution here so this could have been
done a different way I'm not sure they
said they were on the cusp desktop
publishing but who knows okay this is
the multimedia stuff that they are done
this is very interesting too I want to
share this with you it's right here just
had it okay how using these the
dimensions of the page and cutting
things off like this I think that's
really interesting if you designed it as
a whole like this okay I think that's
enough so that was a poster there it
becomes a booklet right milk are you
ready to get into the critique let's do
it that was so inspiring thank you for
sharing those beautiful books
my pleasure so do you want to start I
know you having something up your sleeve
here I do oh my goodness I have a coil
have to go first then III go first let's
see ah let's start sharing my screen and
is that mine that is mine let's see
I would like to probably go start from
here here's what I'll do I probably
would like to let me turn off Milka
probably I'm just gonna go around
picking on a few things on the computer
and then maybe Christo can go over a few
other projects and then I can do some
hands-on stuff as a camera or set up
here to show you how to do you know push
your work even further I I would very
much like to deconstruct experimental
for you because when I say put your foot
on the gas and design with your foot on
the pedal doesn't mean metaphor doesn't
mean to go crash into our tree folks it
means that let go and be fearless
it's a metaphor that I'm using for
designing with typography so it's just a
mindset to let go of fear because fear
can really hinder you it can really stop
you but when you go let go of fear then
the whole world opens up in front of you
what I recommend to my students is
pretend you're three years old if you've
been around some three years olds at
toddlers they're really fearless they
have no idea what's gonna happen if they
jump in the middle of the street they
have no idea what's gonna happen if they
put their finger on the hot stove they
have no idea I'm not saying do that
folks please be safe
what I'm saying in terms of the design
practice be fearless so be fearless
asking yourself what if I do this what
if I do that what's going to happen if I
do this a lot of times I see that people
talk about
oh if you do this this is this gonna
happen if you do that this and this
isn't gonna happen no no no stop you can
talk about things till the cows come
home but the key is to do it so you can
see and experience for yourself what's
gonna happen and let that be memorable
this piece here I thought was really
cool
it had the balance of being experimental
and also very structured as we see it
has the content here so this would be a
nice poster where you can put it out
there where it's both satisfying the
satisfying alluring your audience but at
the same time communicating the message
in eligible clear way this one I thought
this was awesome this was really awesome
and correct me from wrong you I I would
probably create this through a scanner
and I'm not sure how they created this
I'm curious to learn how these were done
but I'm gonna nitpick get nitpicky with
you guys with all due respect this is
not the type of a typography I like to
see after a few weeks of practicing good
typography so this was awesome what we
see here this is gorgeous beautiful
let's make sure we balance that with
very nice beautiful clean typography so
what I did is I'll show you I'm gonna so
it's going to be very fast quick let's
see here I'll zoom in you guys can see
and I'm gonna turn my screen on so look
what happened here
it became cleaner before after let's
zoom out a little bit so I didn't do
much I really did not do much here's
here's before here's after so I moved
this up a little bit more and created
some space and if
before there was something there was
another text over here I'm not seeing it
right now but please folks friends I
should say do not put text where you see
there's an empty space ask yourself how
can the text make a relationship with
the entire page they're all a big family
that they're working together so moving
down here I figure that it's this is
very tight so I decided to make this
experimental area smaller and move it up
to create more room I think we could
still make this smaller and move it up
so we have more room to breathe right
now I'm not very happy with the tight
tight tight margin and I hope this helps
let's just look into it what do we do
here very simple thing we made this line
same width as a stroke of the journal
for graphics and then we have features
which is I think features here let me
see I think it's just one point bigger
this one is 7 point and this one is 6
point that's all it took to create a
tiny little bit of a hierarchy and then
over here what do we have 6 point put it
but in bold and the rest is I Chris I'm
sorry I cheated I went 5 points I know
you said don't make if this was to be
bigger then it wouldn't be 5 points so I
just wanted to show you the relationship
of this whole layout together is this
helpful it is but you know what I want
to do because I have layout open as well
and I'd like to take the crack at it as
well so oh please the beauty of
typography you have Milkha's expert
opinion and then I'm gonna give you my
amateur opinion too okay do me a favor
stop sharing and then i'ma switch over
absolutely I think everybody can learn
that there isn't one way and there's
multiple ways to make this work for you
and what you're trying to achieve so
this is from eunuch Jung Choi and and
both I think both those layouts were but
I only saw like correct
and I talked about okay now unlike nOCA
I actually really really like this thing
and I don't care how you made this it's
kind of marvelous like I look like I
decided like it I was I was I was
critiquing the bottom part how do you do
that okay so I think she was like I
would have done this traditionally and I
thought you had done this traditionally
like using some vinyl letter forms and
just did some really weird TWiki things
but it looks to me like you've bent the
type and added these gradient lighting
effects underneath it which is very
convincing so to me it's like I don't
care how you do it it's either I like it
or I don't so if you spent five minutes
doing it or five hours it doesn't matter
it's the result and I like it a lot so
I'm gonna just play around with it I
haven't designed it before so what I
would do is I'm gonna try and take this
here and I'm just gonna try and see if
this will work okay so I'm going to take
this I'm gonna move the eighth over here
because I feel like it wants to have one
element on this side and I would
probably be a lot more careful with this
if I were designing this for real so I
want to break that apart to kind of
activate the four corners and I don't
actually mind this I think opening it up
as as Milka done gives you a certain
look but I actually kind of like the
compactness of this so I'm just gonna
give this I'm just gonna nudge it up and
that's all I want to do to that and then
I'm gonna change the weight to this so
one thing that we talked about last week
a little bit but we're going to do a
little bit more of it today which is
this is that lines can be like typefaces
so you can create different weights by
and hierarchy by changing it so there
it's a half a point so what if we made
it like a full point and you create a
little bit more contrast between this so
beestings anchor the Journal of graphic
design January 2018 and this is a little
divider I think that's working just fine
and then maybe just make this bold so
right now it's a medical light I'll just
make it bold and boom maybe that's all I
needed
beautiful oh my god that's beautiful I
love it okay this is the hero and I
think to Milkha's point it could be a
bigger smaller if we can try rotating it
we can try different lots of different
things it doesn't really matter
inherently I think the layout was very
good to begin with just a little simple
simplicity here and there if you wanted
to you could probably add a line or
something to pull elements of this up
here but
what do you think about those two type
elements at the top at the top area I
actually mean delete it and see okay in
there you like it without it I like her
yeah I like it with it I I think it's
because there's so much happening with
that middle image it doesn't need any
buzz around it it needs to celebrate its
beauty in the most simple form and I
think that's what you and Kong was
trying to do yeah
okay so do you want to take take the
next go or you want me to go oh sure I
can take the next go let's see okay are
we yes we're almost like very fluid now
what we should give ourself a pat in the
back for where we came and where we are
we're like who's in zum-zum okay all
right I am going to move this here and
am i sharing my page with you yet yes
yes also okay now let's go to mo okay
cool some cool work here this is a good
example of where you know friends spend
a lot of time and then the typography is
suffering so bad good typography is
really important but there are some good
typography happening here what I really
appreciate it is everything except this
area and this and this at the same token
I really love the fact that you can come
over here let me deselect that command
shift G that's if I could do that now C
ungroup I want to say on
level most layouts are so complicated
yeah I came and copy/paste them and move
them yeah I okay you know what I created
my own layer so let me see okay there we
go so what I loved about this this first
of all I got rid of all those white text
and I was like woohoo I'm having such a
good time exploring this because this
pattern is so awesome to move it around
and you can create all these different
cool things so that this is very perfect
but let's make it
unperfect because then it becomes very
exciting do you agree with that Chris
and then I lift these here and I left
these here and what I did is I took this
information here and I brought it in as
black text it's still not there still
not perfect but I loved it but here's
the thing I what I thought that we could
do this okay and what I thought we could
do this if I can see the layers
correctly yet see it's crazy crazy crazy
let me see if I can only select this
layer what happens if it's yeah this is
I want okay what happens if you hold on
the shift key and do this and do that
and do this now let's see what happens
if we just select this what is this one
ah good good good what happens if we
come over here and move this around you
get all these really cool effects and
the overlap oh the overlap is so awesome
you might say it's not readable yes but
I want you to experiment and try folks
talking about failing forward this is
what's failing forward is no one's gonna
get hurt and what's gonna happen is the
benefit is that you're gonna discover
cool things that you may come in and say
oh I'm gonna use a portion of that for
maybe something else or for an idea
moving forward chrysolite
about this one to me this wasn't as
experimental I'm sorry this was an
experiment oh [ __ ] me I did a good try
but the question is what if you do it
with hand cut and paste
I'm sorry so we can say explain why for
you it's not experimental the effects
are cool experimental for me and I will
show you is really really experiment and
then bring good typography in there and
one of the examples that you showed at
the bottom right of one of my students
what she did is she experimented first
and then she brought good typography
sitting next to it so here right now
we're trying to do two things make it
readable and make it experimental right
now the experiment is like like a little
like a little like a little touch like a
little tease it's like it's like you
what are these stuff here is it's
bothering my eye do I need to clean my
glasses I'm sorry ma I'm not
disrespecting you in any way what's
about the work that we're talking about
I just I'm being I'm exaggerating so you
guys can get the idea moving over here
this was cool good job good job cool
effect and of course this was done on
the computer I just want to see how we
can make this a little bit better just a
little bit better and I'm gonna go and
look at my layers and this is the other
layer so you see by getting rid of that
and I know he probably was trying to
create some kind of a effect that it's a
paper that is rotating but the effect of
taking this black area out and letting
this white area seep through the
background is more powerful and what I
think is I brought these lines closer
and I overlapped I overlapped with the
typography it's still readable this is
what we talked about pushing the edge of
the envelope it still looks like the
paper is bending right but then you
don't need these burned edges that that
just detracts
from the beauty of what we're doing over
here and by the way more I really
appreciated how you had both outline and
edible edible edible texts thank you
editable text sorry I haven't had my
coffee yet um Chris I can go one more
and then we can maybe switch okay if you
move on to MA if you're moving on from
mo let's let's switch right there okay
yeah yes yes P I'm sorry yeah so then I
will then take over take over somebody
wants to buy Mazda address as I said in
the comments okay so so mo there there's
something really hypnotic that's
vertigo-inducing about this and the
problem I have with this is the
legibility I think you have something
really cool and as I examined it and and
zoomed into the file it's like file I'm
not quite sure how you made this but it
looks like it took you a lot of time so
I want to applaud you for that so all I
did was I took this which i think is
your coolest thing there's concentric
circles that are radiating out from the
center that's kind of resonating by that
you're creating I just paste it in here
this is pretty cool
I like this a lot and when I paste it in
here I mean I have put it in the exact
same spot but that's okay but if you
zoom in guys look at this thing here
somehow mo cut the letter forms out
along the arc the curve here did you see
that detail and just look like this
typography in there and it's he's worked
on this so you know yeah full respect
right there look at that man that's
really cool cuz I thought well let me
just move the type I can't because it's
locked in there in that exact position
so if we examine this and we say okay if
this is cool
could it be better and what would we do
to add to this thing I don't know just
yet but I notice here you've hyphenated
the gern no and it's kind of funny and
that there's the singular hyphenation
here because i think you wanted this
type to break the way it does and to be
honest it's not a beautiful rag that
you've created here so let me draw on
top of this with a color and see if you
guys can see what I'm talking about here
so I'm gonna draw a line he
it comes out it's strange rag to me I
think you would have been better off and
I'm gonna do right now so I'm just gonna
put type here and I've been the journal
or graphic design just yet but it will
be Chris while you're doing this my
suggestion is for rags to have it short
long short long so this way you avoid
creating shapes mm-hmm exactly perfect
okay so what I I wanted to show you is
if we had another shot at this I would
just do it something like that and not
not get into breaking it unnaturally
like that so this is like because it's
every word it the shape is gonna be the
shape you don't need to manipulate it
much more than that but as I'm doing
this I'm starting to realize too that I
need some white element on this and I
think that's why you did what you did
here but using these thin lines and a
thin typeface it makes it very very hard
to read okay so this is where I think
you need some white maybe you need some
black but you need something and let
this thing in the background be textural
okay so I'm gonna delete this now okay
so we need something black we need
something dark so I'm gonna just try to
put something on top and see what
happens here let me switch over to my
colors here and what happens when you
add an element to black maybe that's all
you needed to have something black and
then you could put your white type in
here Milka I just want to make sure I
know you have somewhere to be and you
have a hard out at one we have to get
out of 130 at the latest because Ben is
doing a webinar so I want to make sure
that we get to your cutting and pasting
and doing things with your hands is that
the plan today yes yes okay so I've
doing it live live so I don't want to do
too much this but I believe that this is
more textural what you have in the
background so you really need to make
sure everything else is legible for
whatever reasons I couldn't see the
layout the way it was meant to be it was
just all outline so I can't manipulate
it that much but I just want to show you
by adding a few elements in here
something
much more quiet and reserved maybe
there's the way for it to work now I
want to show you something more quick so
I'm gonna delete this I can't delete it
like that it'll delete everything you
remember this thing that I did at the
top here where is it
oh I hit it this thing here all these
little things oh I know what look I can
I could steal this copy this go back
down to most layout I'll paste it and
I'll show you what I mean yes yes yes
paste it here okay having some black
having some white allows design to work
so that's one way yeah good job
beautiful oh let me let me do what I
intended to do Chris you have the magic
touch it's been such a pleasure watching
you live seeing you happen to seeing how
you create this just been such a gift to
me thank you you're welcome thank you
for saying that appreciate you saying
that
so here I just copy and paste it I think
at the top and put it in here to kind of
add some texture so you guys need to
realize some things are just not legible
and don't fight it and try and pretend
like it is and we know that we need to
add some black and some white to this
kind of layout which is very grave if
you squint your eyes it's just a very
neutral gray so doing something like
that is gonna really make it pop that's
all I want to encourage you to now over
here if i zoom into this this layout I
think you're building on off of things
that you've achieved previously it looks
Photoshop to me but doesn't really
matter you've got some of this a
wrinkled sticker paper kind of wheat
posts we pasted posters but the problem
is there's so much that's going on so
many different things I started to look
at this thing that you have underneath I
think there's something beautiful in
here so what I did was I yes everything
yes I agree got away and I left it with
this and I think this is really nice
here right so resonate the journal for
graphic design I think if you want to
bring some of that back in here's how I
would do it I'll shoot it's one of these
things that I can't manipulate okay
I had some type of a site here let me
just grab something that type let me
grab this copy that
get back into here and I'm gonna pay
something in Eric just just demonstrate
it I an idea not to say like this solves
your problem but if we took this and I'm
gonna match the rotation of this right I
don't know and why don't you know
because I see the triangle okay good
that opened that up nice like we don't
have to have crazy on top of crazy on
top of crazy we just need a little bit
of something okay nice beautiful and
that's the layout and it can work and
eat something right up here yeah I don't
like this little barcode thing that you
created - pretty cool maybe a little
something here actually actually I can
just push the names up further up and
then create add more letting and I would
do it yeah I was just saying like
something oh yes you are so right that
just made it perfect okay okay all right
now back to you Oh back to me awesome
all right I like this shirt screen
alright our next friend what do we have
here and I know you're gonna talk about
this I'm gonna get more and more in
depth as we go along I saw this actually
on Instagram I saw the process that she
went through and I really loved it so
basically what the process is she
scanned in a piece of paper on the
scanner and as the scanner scanning
she's very gently slightly moving it up
and down so this is how this was created
and then but I noticed I'm being it
picking you guys I noticed one thing I'm
like okay one two three four we've got
this area equal to this area so the
height of this is equal to height of
this and where do we have resonate
almost in the middle folks be aware of
these things
please so how can we make this layered
even more dynamic so I came in here and
asked myself that question and I played
around with it a little bit and I'm not
saying it's the best solution but you
see how it became more of a dynamic
layout so you have the law of third
happening here so you have the 2/3
versus the 1/3 right this is this is
still bothering me this versus this
because it's equal be aware of equal I
again you want to practice ones 3s and
5s and 7s versus twos and fours because
twos and fours make things symmetrical
and flat or as one threes and fives
anything in that ratio makes it more
dynamic so very great process really
enjoyed it and also I'm like here ok if
this is going to be experimental just
just go experimental I died I wasn't
very clean with these guys I just I just
wanted to show you about layout and then
this one this is a good example of where
you want to get your hands and feet wet
with typography but then at the same
time you're holding yourself back
because you want to make sure everything
is readable so how can we make this even
better notice we've got the yin yang yin
yang yang Yang and we've got this
cutting almost in the middle diagonally
right and then we have these and this
kind of boxing the page satellites folks
only use it when it's needed not because
you have to put it in there we already
have a satellite going out and another
one going I said I'm not sure if we need
this this in relation to this looks good
for
I'm not sure so the question is how can
these boxes of text have a relationship
with what's happening here to resonate
and of course look at all that white
space that we have here all that bubble
space I like to say there's a lot of
bubble space here and bubble space says
that you want to be safe
right that's what we're doing with
quarantine and staying at home so we
don't get : 19 we have a bubble space so
I came here and I said well what if
we're at sea not everything locked okay
why can I move this so that's a little
bit under myself not being there but you
know I went in here I said would like to
play with this because I'm not crazy
about that I came in here brought the
name of the artist tried to make some
kind of a connection and then you know
you had the date over here I snuggled it
in here I closed the journal form
I closed down the letting I think I
could also close that and the tracking
here as well I kept the graphic design
and I just played it around a little bit
here and I even became so playful that I
came over here and say ha ha what if
it's s and then there's a tab and then
the name of the name and then the rest
of the name so he go for kukuda or army
and hope men soak an experimental no
one's gonna get hurt this is what makes
these things fun and attractive and
seductive the beauty of experimental is
that you're communicating another layer
of meaning with that reading you're
looking at it and you feel it you know
this is going to be an exciting show
with a lot of cool yummy
creative work being shown by these
artists so maybe a readability and
legibility is not necessary for this ask
yourself that question you can do so
many areas
variations you can do this save it and
say okay I did that let me see what I
can do now this is what I'm talking
about by putting your foot on the gas
and just boom boom just go make him mess
but make but spend a lot of time on the
mess
don't spend like a five minute second
timeframe under mess spend a lot of time
I'm making it so messy that it becomes a
cooked meal I hope that helps this one I
didn't want to touch it I don't know if
it does but I'm super hungry it is 15
can we look at something here can I see
the original and what you've done to it
yes do you mean yes yes this is just
those two can you zoom in a little bit
more and maybe hide your palates just so
we can see yes beautiful let me just see
this I what I really really like this
thing that that has happened at the
bottom there at the bottom lower
quadrant I really really like this
overlapping asymmetrical topography
things that are that to me is the
magical corner I think you've done the
best you can here to try to revise
layout and I just think the the resonate
this sorta type isn't doing a whole lot
for me personally right so if we just
got rid of that I think your layout
would be much better I know that we're
asking you to push and try things but
sometimes in the experimentation it just
doesn't work out yeah that's a good
lower corner is this mmm this area yes
the whole area I know it's so yummy it's
so intriguing and you want to read it
it's it's like I want to discover what
it says a lot of people like to discover
information and for them that's very
very rewarding and you have to know
exactly you would have to know who
you're a client and your audience is
because if your audience likes to be
spoon-fed this is not gonna work this is
actually going to frustrate them but you
if your audience is about discovering
finding information they're gonna love
this sort of yummy things Chris I am
good with this you were gonna talk about
another layout before I stopped you
oh no no I said I didn't touch this one
I didn't touch this one I don't know
about these being where they're placed
why because look at the eat that space
between these two it's almost equal from
that Journal from journal 2/4 and from
graphic to design folks be aware of
these things I know you're not gonna
like me call your folks my daughter
hates it when I say folks so I'm gonna
say friends I think I'm saying folks but
I'm not happy with the layout but
friends please be mindful of creating
these layouts in such a way where
there's the where the bubble space is
not saying you you you me me me bring
unification to one another and that's
what I was trying to do here I was
wanted to I wanted to create this
unification with one another so we have
first read ok first rich focal point and
we have second brief focal point so
we're creating it depth here I just
wanted to talk about layout and what's
next
shall I move on Chris or would you like
to hop and talk about that one because I
know you had that one on yours I have it
on mine I was just saying to Luca I
really like the experimentation that you
were doing there I think it's really
nice I think for all the things that
Milko saying work on that the original
layout has to be good you have to follow
those principles and then you start to
tweak it and make it all melty and weird
so exactly good you thank you exactly
everyone's doing a good job folks we're
just here trying to push it even further
the work that you're doing we really
appreciate both Chris and I went through
these exercises we both think we did not
sleep we did not eat hey Chris so we
know the pain and the agony that you're
going through it but it's so rewarding
because I bet you after this class
you're going to be whipping out those
layouts just as if it's as if you're
drinking water it's a Persian expression
drink water cuz it's so easy
because what would you like to do next
please I think you you want to tackle
another one or you okay I can tackle
another one with pleasure
all right let's tackle another one then
after you finish that one I'm gonna go
and work a little bit and I want you to
get hands-on with some printed materials
okay I think we want to switch gears
because okay
being mindful time you have to leave a
one o'clock don't you yes yes and I'm
running out of I'm running out of
battery really fast I don't know if I do
have my charger with me so maybe once we
switch I can do that yeah all right
let's sorry okay let's talk about this
one again it's not it's I don't know who
did this and it's with all the respect
it's about the work it's not about who
or you or me yes I just want to make
sure people are clear about that you're
right
thank you so we we always have the same
issue here kind of a dead space here
this is nice this is nice this is nice
but are they do they have a relationship
with one another no they don't and let's
see would it be this one yes it is this
one so all I did it's the same
ingredient it's the same thing all I did
is I created a relationship by bringing
this closer to this and moving the
journal over here so there's this
beautiful relationship that this is
taking your eye out and this is bringing
you back in again you comes in you look
at this brings you down here you read
this takes you out brings you in and
maybe takes you out and brings you in
again and with this this is what we want
in terms of an active page so yes once I
get outside they want to help me I
appreciate that I have my charger in my
bag let's see what else do I didn't play
with the type as much but I what I did I
just take the January and February here
and I went in here and added some funky
space in there
and look at the law of third that we're
doing we're doing law of third here and
we're also doing law of third here so we
have two laws of there we have the first
read law of third here and then we have
the second read of love third there I
hope that helps and I Chris I want to
tackle this by hand and I want to talk
about this quickly because I know
they're waiting for me to help me out is
that okay thank you so much I appreciate
it all right
you have such a such awesome team here
Chris people good people okay so I saw
this one and I'm like oh this is so
awesome good job in creating this 3d
effect it has that a sure look to it but
then it's like it's like just sitting
there in the dead space with no friends
around it
no interaction all that space around it
it's dead how do we make it active and
this is experimental right so we can
repeat so what if we come here and push
and pull so I made this larger and I
make this a little bit smaller I push
that to the corner top left as like as
if there's more happening and brought
this down so it goes out of the page and
what I did is I just just pretend this
is half of the name and these are the
rest of the name and then just play
around with this this was so much fun to
play with because you couldn't go wrong
with it anything you put anywhere it
just speaks to the layout look at that
it's like a sure actually a sure move
over this is this was so much fun
oh that's even better no we may need
something here well it's making it dead
end let's see I should have command Z
command Z maybe we'll bring this baby
here and see how does that work whoo so
dynamic awesome job awesome
experimentation again
you have done this design good job save
it now say what else can I do
and have fun if you're not having fun
that you're not doing it right that is
my motto
so those of you had fun you know what
I'm talking about and those of you who
did then and you were like I don't know
I'm scared then you're not doing it
right get rid of the fear and fear what
does fear stands for Chris fantasize
experience appearing real right there
yeah that's Errol Gerson's could folks
this is the beauty of design no one is
gonna get hurt it's just a piece of
layout you can do so many practices and
if you look at David Carson though based
on Christo after his book that he should
i he does a lot of these layouts boom
boom boom boom boom boom so many
practice and as you may know you might
have heard a lot of 100 if you spend 100
hours on something you become decent
love 10,000 if you spend 10,000 hours
then you become an expert like crystal I
do want to say a couple things the
original layout I I didn't pick this
layout because although it's really
interesting we've seen these kinds of
layouts before I can't read resonate in
there is it Ren Nate there was the Z
okay you know I I chose this at this
layout because I saw the potential in
making it better in terms of a layout so
it is yeah it's our e-z upside down no
oh I see the Z's over here so it's our e
Z and eight hey it's experimental you
got to give him a break okay talk about
it yes well let's review let's let's
zoom in on your two things and hide
everything so we can look at the before
and after a little bit so we can talk
about it oh sure yeah okay so
as soon as mocha hides all that junk
sorry about that
is that better yes it is it's much
better okay so this is from Yan Zhang so
I like it it's a good layout I like the
negative space I like this kind of
dimensionality stair-step the emcee
Esher thing that you got going on and I
think milk is trying to take it and use
all the space and I think there's some
interesting things going there I just
want to make sure you're experimenting
with the design and not with the
spelling because I see the are the e and
then I see the N if it's upside down Z
and then and cuz you know if you take
the air and it becomes a Z so then
what's out there character B between the
N and the 8 what is that this that yeah
what is that hey listen I don't get
nitpicky on these things because it's
experimental and it's through
experimenting that you discover new
ideas maybe this could be an inspiration
for a letter form typeface design I
don't know I'm just putting it out there
it might inspire somebody okay I think
the most interesting thing for me is the
way that you drew the letter e because
he took the normal he and you folded it
it could build a staircase like that and
the way the lighting hits it and I think
that's your most successful part of this
I would love for you to take the other
letter forms and actually fold them in
real space and study them and see what
else you can achieve by bending certain
parts and folding over 90 degrees what
else you can create then from that make
sure you treat this in a way that
because it's like if it's not meant to
be read don't even get close to spelling
it right or spell it right or something
is something is just messing me up with
this layout but I like the effect I like
the composition it's really nice and
then you're you're really trying to push
the rest of the space and activate it I
really like the exploration and and
again I totally understand the concept
of the Z and the N if you rotate it it
could be both so I appreciate for trying
that out as an in for experimental
awesome job
Chris I think from here on let me see
I'm gonna probably get my hands and feet
right because we're gonna rock that time
with these ones okay but I will can I
switch this back to you and give me five
minute break yeah yeah yeah and so you
continue you take the ball from here on
and I'll be back thank you so much yes
you're welcome I think at this time we
should probably run that video that
Stuart's prepared for us and I'm gonna
figure out how to do that in one second
here let's see oh we prepared a little
video for you guys a little commercial
break here while Milkha is getting ready
and where's my QuickTime video I cannot
find it shoot maybe I won't do that one
second guys oh there it is I see it so
I'm gonna play this if you're enjoying
these critiques inspired by the work you
see and want to get better at layout and
design for print web film or television
we have a course available on our site
that is designed just for you it will
help you to learn the rules of
typography how to create contrast
control focal points achieve
asymmetrically beautiful layouts how to
critique your own work keyboard
shortcuts and include my personal tips
on how to build an asset library so you
can design at the speed of thought as an
added bonus students who enrolled in the
course can participate in future
critiques get updates as we release them
and a time-lapse video of me working on
layouts not available anywhere else you
can jump in anytime work at your own
pace and take your typography skills to
the next level that's it for me I hope
to see you in the future
[Music]
all right I hope that worked it out work
guys all right Jonna give it did
yes it did thankfully something works
whoo you guys don't know how much this
is like the Millennium Falcon here we're
just barely getting by so we're back
here in Illustrator okay so this was yin
yang Zhang's work here like I said I
really appreciate this e and I think
this folded paper thing you're onto
something I'd love for you to do that
with some of the other letter forms okay
what else should we look at here mm-hmm
okay why don't I mention this one here
this is for Michael Lau Michael Lyles
layout here I really like what he's done
here with this thing and he's
manipulating the letter forms is one of
the things I suggested that you do for
experimental layout he's also added some
random characters in here kind of
interesting and I like this there's
something really funky weird and looks
like a barcode melting type the one
problem and the one problem is the a
because the a doesn't have a horizontal
crossbar at the top by stretching the a
what has happened here he's created a
thicker letter form which really jumps
out at me in a way that it's not
supposed to so Michael let's figure out
a different letter to stretch and pull
across or make this thinner so that you
can keep the whit's consistent because
it's drawing a natural attention to
itself there and it throws me off okay
that's the one thing I would suggest
that you do so we could do that I think
right now by taking this and just make
it more like that it's still too thick
so being mindful of the ratios in if you
wanted to you could just copy this this
one here and just put it over there I
think it's still one pixel too thick
yeah a little bit better for me okay but
I like that he also includes parts of
letter forms on this side the one thing
I probably wouldn't want him to do is to
do this part well I'm going to draw on
top of this let me switch to color so
you guys can see where my colors at be
mindful the space in the shape you're
creating that wedge here
whereas this one is going in and out
going in and out I like that watch these
kinds of shapes here okay Michael I'm
gonna do these two things so we can
easily fix that just by taking this type
and oops let's see what I can do here
inherently the files are a little bit
more complicated this week because of
the experimental nature maybe I don't
know what the importance of this is but
I wanted to bring it back in
you should really bring this one back in
so let me go and do preview mode here
and see if I can't select this once you
go preview you can kind of see the
secret sauce being applied ah
I think grab it correctly let's bring it
out maybe like right here so they can
come in and out it's still not quite
right but at least that's the idea all
right
and there's another layout here that
somebody else also did one where they
were pushing the letter forms around
this is from Kyle Daley so there's a lot
that's going on here and I think Kyle's
doing the same thing but this time he's
keeping the proportions okay so I'm not
bothered by it the resin and then he did
Roman numerals the Roman numeral
numerals are a little hard to read here
I think the ideas that's VIII but it
just reads a resin V so so maybe just do
three blocks that are similar so let's
see if we can do that together and see
if it helps the layout any little bit at
all I'll just copy it over here now this
week I realized something
no I don't want to change your layouts
too much I think I want to see if we can
just make a small tweak keep the
integrity of the original design in
tension and not mess around with it too
much I think this is too thin maybe
something like that
so that's one thing and that also opens
up some of the space here when you use
lines like this Kyle I want to make sure
it's tied to something that there's a
reason for it
either ties to another element here or
this somehow reaches and hit something
else on top but I'm not seeing it hit
anything does it hit this no it doesn't
okay so in a case like this all you have
to do is take this and bring it and
maybe hit hit some other grid line here
I'm not sure it could hit this line you
can also duplicate this as an element
here and just make it hit this hit every
grid line I have to say it's really
quiet without Milka no it doesn't now I
see that it's so thick in a corner it's
not too thick it's too wide so let me
hide this for a second that I can make
sound effects if you want you have to do
it the way no good but appropriately
appropriately and I just randomly so I'm
gonna grab all these things I'm back I
heard some people want to make t-shirts
with the word tight tight tight hey I
need copyright on that okay it's a few
small changes what I'm feeling here Kyle
is that some of these elements are not
talking to each other and they really
need to like this is feeling a little
lonely here as does this so I don't I
don't know how to solve that just yet
but I'm gonna start to delete things
usually when I'm confused I don't know
what to do I just start deleting stuff
okay so I'll take this and delete that
take this type hey I need copyright on
that few small changes what I'm feeling
here yeah I'm ready I'm but I'm noticing
I don't have a printout of one of them
maybe you only have 30 minutes okay
can i yeah yeah yeah maybe maybe tell me
if you can help me but I always I can
talk through it shall I share screen
with you or whatever you want okay let's
switch screen then okay awesome
thank you I heard it was very quiet
without me okay
moving forward we talked about that line
now we're gonna talk all the way sorry
I'm waiting for this little guy okay
here we go was this one yep this one ah
that's my one talkback okay all right
this one is actually I do have a
printout of it oh it didn't print that's
why I didn't choose it
hmm those lines did not come out let me
double-check yeah they did not print out
unfortunately they printed out like this
okay
so what I was hoping to do with that
layout Chris and tell me if this would
be something we could do it quickly on
computer which I don't think so
is to go in there and put my ruler on
top of it and cut it vertically
vertically vertically vertically are we
looking at right now we look at your
screen or something else that I'm not
saying okay yeah look at my screen okay
and I was thinking like we go in here
why can't we see my let's see okay let's
go in here and let's just draw it is
just cut randomly okay very randomly on
some of these vertically
okay just randomly so these you see
these guidelines what if we were to
print this out and slice the piece on
these lines and then you move it up and
down you move each piece a little bit up
another one a little bit so you create
this really funky effect for that area
resonate and it's going to make it even
be more interesting and have more depth
does this make sense you know I'm
talking back all right
is what I was planning to do but
apparently it did not print out I just
this area I missed out I can move on to
another ones do we have any question on
this one what are we watching you do I'm
gonna go live now I'm gonna yeah okay
alright so let's see we're gonna we're
gonna look at some of these and are we
live here awesome thank you let me share
with you what I have when I'm working by
hand I have the best matte board cutting
board I have my exacto knife I have some
white tools definitely scissors and I
have a magnified glass as well okay and
light right am I going too fast
no and I also what I brought is I
brought our girl plastic wrap okay
I also brought mylar these are so
beautiful you can do so many by the way
one of my thesis I use this you can see
it on window alright let's see so I was
thinking this is so cool this is so
beautiful I really liked how what they
did is they they went ahead and put
their drawing combined with this at
first I didn't see the drawing I saw the
lines I didn't know it was a figure
drawing I was what a beautiful way of
integrating these lines of drawings with
the forms and the shape of the letters
it did print out with some of the gray
background make sure when you scan
things in the background is totally
white so we don't see any of these great
lines but I was wondering what if we
come here and do this can you see this
whoa boom and then you come over here
and I also created these these outline
so I can come here and I can come and
crop so you might say well how am I
gonna get this in the computer you take
your picture and then you come and then
you Photoshop the lines out and one of
the pieces that you showed Chris from my
website that's exactly what the students
did they will go through this
experimental and then they go into
Photoshop and then they get rid of the
outlines so the white blends in with the
background does this help yes okay cool
so you can do so many cool things with
water and glass another one that we have
integrating these lines of drawing I
don't know let's just move forward
here's another one see you see you guys
see how cool that is I did not have to
use any photoshop I did not have to use
any illustrator right there there's your
answer you can do so many cool things by
these effects I can also bring the saran
wrap this is what I wanted to do I also
come here and the saran wrap and make
these effects okay and then come here
and use these crops to recrop my layout
these are very powerful tools to use
these cropping tools because you can
design your layout and come here and
find out what else can I do and then
take this piece put it in microwave let
it or toaster and let the plastic melt
for like maybe just a few seconds to see
what happens as it integrates itself
with the background try these little
experimentations that folks and see how
it works
just
very safe okay I don't want you guys
getting hurt in that aspect or we talked
about these two which is really easy
this was an easy peasy piece I was like
okay it's very computer like what did
you come here and just crumble it either
way this is exactly how Frank Gehry
designs his buildings he crumbles pieces
of paper and he looks at him and he goes
there
there's my building right yeah so what
do you come here and crumble it up but
remember last week forgive me with all
due respect I said garbage in garbage
out
no you have to start with a good layout
where's a focal point here where's the
focal point I don't know it right now it
hasn't cooked itself yet it seems like
there could be a focal point here but
it's an outline maybe it needs to be
thicker and bigger I'm not sure there's
a focal point here right now but it
needs to work itself out and where's my
cropping tools and then again you come
here and take your picture that became
more interesting and pure would be like
Oh what what effect did you use what
Photoshop effect did you use right Chris
that's right I'm gonna ask my team to
stabilize the camera it's making me a
little seasick here I apologize okay and
then let's see what is this one this one
oh this is so cool you guys you can see
this right okay they went in there and
did cutting and pasting in the computer
great good job good job what if we come
here and do all of that here too folks
this is live so excuse any type of
accidents which which by the way the
accidents happy accidents are your best
friends right and those are certain
dippity we do want happy accident we
talk about we talk about failing forward
what does failing forward means
we talk about feeling comfortable and
feeling comfortable in anti beauty this
is exactly what these assignments help
you do they make you feel comfortable
being in the ants being Iraq being
surrounded with uncertainty there are so
many beautiful solutions and uncertainty
look already it looks great already it
looks even more dynamic and I can come
over here and and then I can come here
and recrawl it so where's my white
background I have I brought a white
background here I can perfectly I don't
know what's happening
what was this okay I think this was over
here yeah mocha D suggest this happens
almost at last steps because you'd have
to do everything digitally and then
bring it in and take photos is that the
process this is part of the process good
question at the very end you do scan it
in and then you clean it up but this is
the process that you go through so you
know this was such a beautiful piece you
can do so much with this as you cut it
up I just want to show you let go let go
that's what I want to show you guys it's
not about creating beautiful pictures
all those books like crystal was showing
you guys none of them started perfect
they all started from these experimental
stuff where people went in there and
tried this and this and that and then
they figured out what else can we do as
I'm moving forward this could have been
last week's assignment I think right I
don't have a black marker okay what if
we come over here and it's hand drawn
what if we come over here we do draw
more hand draws you know we just have a
good time woohoo I'm going into the zone
I feel like I'm doing all these strands
work never somebody stop me stop me we
gonna do a beep right now be part
okay do you see that and then I come
over and I got you I hate it you know
what I'm gonna do yeah this is so
pleasurable folks let go and when you
let go you find answers that you did not
expect that you didn't anticipate and
that's where creativity stems from okay
did you guys get the idea yes I think
you're opening it up to everybody like
maybe they didn't think about it the
right way the box yeah and I'm sorry I'm
going through this really fast
what else did I want to do oh they
printed this out for me okay cool
awesome thank you guys so I'm gonna just
come over here and just as I as I
mentioned I'm just gonna slice slice and
I'm gonna make sure that these are not
the same so they're like small medium
large
okay maybe too many slices but one more
okay and then I'm gonna come over here
and just move it up a little bit move it
up just a little bit up and down just to
create that kind of a wiggle effect
I want to thank your team for printing
this out for me I appreciate that
they're aces now milk oh we probably
don't recommend you normally cut against
a plastics surface because you'll ruin
that triangle it's uh oh you mean this
this triangle yeah usually you want to
use a metal edge because otherwise the
yes that triangle won't last but yeah
you're right thank you Chris yeah just
best practices you know yeah I'm
practicing too I'm experimenting with
this okay all right moving forward let's
see where are we and
sweet so already it's beginning to look
a little bit interesting you see that
and and now so you come over here you
take a picture what happened we lost
audio did you run our batteries in our
mic Jonah
hello she ran out of battery give us a
couple seconds okay thanks for the
feedback so while she's working on this
I can narrate over it I think but I
haven't she's gonna charge your laptop
real quick okay
so as we're looking at this what Milka
said before about garbage in garbage out
you can see this is that no amount of
experimentation is gonna save a really
bad layout they can make it more
interesting but you have to start with
good bones really good structure okay
and I see that in the comments here
people I call this is more typography as
illustration and expression instead of
plain communication well I don't know
what tipped off that it is called
experimental typography and so we want
you to be expressive we want you to try
things so weeks one through six was all
about communication structure layout
hierarchy focal points violence contrast
scale flow all those kinds of things
right so this week we want to introduce
a whole nother visual language for you
to take it from functional gridded and
structured to something now you need to
log in on Zoom something that's
different than way more interesting all
right Chris there's a question your bows
asking how do we keep legibility when
we're doing so much of this experimental
stuff and I guess is that as important
it is it is really still important and
you can do purely expressive typography
in that kind of data spirit you could
totally do that and and we we encourage
that and if you make something really
gorgeous amazing beautiful nobody's
gonna say anything but you'll notice a
lot of times it's the push and pull
between chaos and order because if it's
all ordered that's all very boring it's
a very structured and we get it you took
a type class you're following all the
rules you're staying within the lines
but sometimes you need to have that
spark something different and that's
that spice that adds a kind of element
to your layout that makes it uniquely
you if you go too far it becomes all
painting and collage work I get that but
you can come back to the other side I'm
back Chris can you hear me yes I can
hear you but okay let's see what you're
done okay all right so I'm just trying
to give you guys an idea look at that
and
how long will it take you to do this in
Illustrator or Photoshop I don't know
but it became quite interesting you can
you can also play around by flipping
these guys around making it even more
crazy yes so what do we there we go
[Music]
again I'm trying to show you the idea
play with it this may not be the answer
but it is a process that you can play
around with so talking about
experimental what is experimental about
experimental about is about exploring
it's about discovering the unknown it's
about taking a chance to find solutions
that you didn't intend for as I
mentioned that before what else do we
have here
does this help yeah okay right right up
into the point of which the batteries
ran out on your laptop I know I have I
can do two more Chris would you like me
to please keep going so this was another
layout I saw this right okay this is
kind of flat and what if and and I saw
this and I'm like okay this is very very
dynamic maybe you can combine your
design layout together what if we come
here and cut this guy's up and then you
bring this back bring a part of this in
here I'm not sure what but I I seize
these edges these triangular edges spoke
to me with these triangle edges to me
with me so I came here I'm coming here
and I'm trying to see where the
relationship that I can find and I'm
very aware of love third some I'm gonna
either show very little of the white
area versus the black area or vice versa
or vice versa show a lot of this and and
less of that
I know you're gonna say this is not
readable you can always go in here and
fix it but right now my intention is for
you guys to see the diffuse so you can
see how you can create depth this is
cool no Chris yeah yeah just have fun
and again don't worry about legibility
and readability at this stage get this
interesting and then you can always come
here and use a portion of this and then
use a portion of this to bring in some
clean text in here make sense you can
probably go into Photoshop and take some
of these areas out and then bring text
in here all right what else do we have
have I used my magnifier the miler at
all I don't know where you would find
mine right this is this is 20 years old
Chris
when did I graduate from Art Center
he'll say don't say people don't but hey
I taught there afterwards for another 5
years so I hope you can see but you can
create let's say living with a lot of
these away out of the way so maybe we'll
have some clarity by the way you can
still buy mylar yes
used to go to an art store okay let me
see if I can see it's not quite working
it's not working but it's really cool
because what happens is that you get
this really cool effect from mylar and
you guys get the idea anyone gets Eddie
so what you do is you put your piece of
paper in front of the mylar okay
and then you photograph the mylar then
you photograph the reflection yeah it's
a mirror you know one of those things
that the fairgrounds yes things you get
some really interesting the reason why
it's not working for you is because
whatever is above you is showing up more
prominently than what you want so
usually you're in a room that's white
and so it will work a lot better I like
to do one more thing before I leave and
I just want to say what I'm doing this
what a pleasure it's been to be part of
this group thank you everyone for your
awesome work really enjoyed this thank
you Chris for inviting me and having me
thank you my goodness okay I want to see
if I can do something really fast real
quickly let's see what I want to show
you is this so handy is saying hello
future just woke up and missed the
livestream but this is really crazy
episode loving it Oh glad to hear that
all right okay so we come over here and
now we can use the light source what if
you come over here and see if I can't
get this to where I wanted to get this
this wasn't one of the pieces that Chris
actually chose to show but you can do
some really cool effect if you cut
certain edges and then you bring light
and you shine line below it and then you
photograph it from the top so you need
to become an octopus holding one hand
holding doing this holding doing that I
may not have demonstrated this very well
what's that
maybe another cut yeah another cut where
would you sit maybe yes maybe let's just
just make let's just make some random
cuts yeah
I can't Chris feel free
longshadow there that idea
feel free to please make a suggestion I
suggestion is I'm gonna keep quiet while
you do your thing yeah thank you I'm not
I mean no please talk I wanna make a
comment I love how you bring all of this
analog stuff into the design because
many of us are so stuck designing inside
the computer where yes things will look
the same but this changes everything
yes yes what I really like about this
process is that no matter what no one
can tell you which Photoshop filter you
used you know the engineer said in the
history of graphic design he said that
if you want to change your style you
want to change the way things look just
change the tools it's that I play with
this you have to be in a dark room by
the way in order to be able to see this
when you're in a dark room these cutouts
can do some wonders wonders stuff I do
have a student actually who took
advantage of this idea and she made her
thesis based on this her name is G young
son I was actually checking it out last
night and she does this beautiful
beautiful cutout and she uses the Sun to
communicate the message that she has cut
out she's a she's a media artist now and
this was inspired from these
experimental work what else could we do
so so we did crumbling with it cutting
in paste you can try my lord you can try
as Chris mentioned it printing it out on
a transparency and then spray some water
on it we talked about using some of
these material bake it cook it don't be
afraid of seeing a relationship between
your work you might say oh I see
something really cool happening here and
you guys I'm just gonna do this real
fast okay real fast and there's nothing
wrong with being
wrong here you do want to be wrong you
do want to be not perfect because again
you want to find you want to have
serendipity to be your answer your
friend so what if I come here and I
integrate this design with this design
just pretend that white area is not
there here let's cut it out I should
have used this we have to get off the
air here mark up we're good until right
before 1:30 okay so maybe something like
this to that effect so again you're
creating a relationship relationship
relationship relationship okay so that's
what I like to emphasis making a
relationship and then again you may like
certain areas and then you take that in
and then you bring in and you put your
good typography here cropping is a very
powerful tool a very powerful tool to
use to make your layout even more
dynamic very powerful to see that now
you can say oh my god I didn't do only
one layout I did 500,000 layer I mean
exaggerating but does this make sense in
terms of experimenting yes it makes
total sense and I think hopefully you've
unlocked some exploration for a lot of
our students who are enrolled in the
class to try things that go out of the
box I think a lot of times we think
we're so clever by figuring out a way to
do inside illustrator or Photoshop but
just get your hands dirty and you can
really strange wild things I'll be out
here that I have here is two things one
start with really good high quality
ingredients whenever you're making a
dish you need to add source like really
good stuff some of these layouts what
kind of really busted to begin with so
milk is so hard right now to make it
work right
yes very good point we're do is once you
push beyond the realm of legibility I
need to pull you back I got to pull you
back and make sure that their components
that you feel that are important for the
viewer to read make sure those are
legible I know there's gonna be a large
group of people are gonna hate on this
video I already know it because of what
has happened in the past but maybe
there's a more educated crowd that's
showing up to our channel these days and
here's why they're gonna hate this
because they don't understand that they
can't process this and in feeling and
doing what we're doing and hurting
legibility that their God is Eligibility
that this is not allowed in that world
and that's okay if this doesn't work for
you go back two weeks one through six
and stay in that sandbox totally okay
you have a wonderful fruitful career
this stuff it's actually not that easy
to do and get it right and what we're
trying to do is show you the world of
possibilities and to encourage you to
play and that's what we're doing here
and it's armed with the knowledge from
weeks one through six you can make any
of these things work yes and friends
these are not masterpieces these are
just exercises to help you develop
seeing more possibilities you cannot
create a perfect beautiful design by
just doing it okay you got to do a lot
of these experimental stuff so you know
where to go where not to go like as I
was doing this I could see oh no no no
no I don't want to go there this is not
talking to me or oh yes this is great
this is inspire me you use this to make
your work even better it's not that this
is the final piece and that's what I'm
gonna give to the client and that's
going to be the absolute piece no these
are pieces to give you food for your
thoughts to nurture you they're like
vitamins for your body to into nourish
you to be able to become better
designers by experimenting make sense
and crystal you rephrase it very
beautifully so these things are at least
happy little moments of serendipity of
discovery two happy accidents the
wabi-sabi if you will you're gonna do
things that you didn't know you could do
and that's the
beautiful part of Milkha's demonstration
so mocha I know you have an important
meeting that you have to run to and
we're gonna kicked off the air here
pretty soon by Ben's webinar so I want
to thank you on behalf of everybody for
the many weeks of contribution that
you've made I want to tell every single
person if you really enjoy this and if
you like milkis enthusiasm or energy and
a professionalism
we're gonna be working on a class
together I don't have the details just
yet but like I said it's gonna be under
30 people you're gonna be able to enroll
in the class so the seats are gonna be
very very limited you're gonna have four
hours with milk each week to go over the
design assignments and you're gonna walk
away with two portfolio pieces so stay
tuned for that we'll drop that
information when it becomes available
down below so I just want to let you
know you've had a really very generous
sample of what Milkha's like to work
with to have her as an instructor so
based on that you guys get to make the
decision if this is something you want
more of or not I want to get back into
layout so milk on behalf of everybody
thank you very much for doing this thank
you thank you to everybody for letting
me work with you on your pieces it was
it's been a pleasure and I hope to
continue working with all of you in
their future and this was a Herculean
effort from our entire team doing it 35
cameras working
switching across the universe is two
different states now I'm just kidding
we're in the same state but all right
I'm gonna share my screen and we're
gonna try to finish this out before the
hour is up and we get booted from this
thing all right
I'm gonna back in Luke so while Milko is
doing her amazing magic I got a chance
to spend some time with this layout so
here's what I did Kyle I altered the
letter form so that there aren't
unnatural heavy blocks and there's a
time and place to do this kind of
knocking out the counters and I'm gonna
show you a layout with that in a second
and that could be really cool and I
thought that there were a lot of
different elements that weren't
necessary working together so I wanted
them to talk to each other
plus I thought everything got a little
boxy and that's why I added these
circular elements it's purely graphic
it's not a communication thing it's not
even conceptual but my instincts told me
that I needed something in there to
bring it together you'll notice you like
when we get experimental I let things
like this overlap I know you can't
totally read it and it's totally okay
and it's just part of the design the
spirit of what it is we're doing I know
I cut off this list but
that's what I would do for this layout
and let me know if you think that was
helpful I also had to fix in the letter
forms here because of the heaviness of
that basically was pulling me into areas
that I thought were unimportant the H
that R and the N so I just wanted to
capture your original intent and do
something like that I also want to give
a some acknowledgement to everybody else
that submitted laya I'm not gonna be
able to go in here because these layouts
are very tough to critique right so URI
takashima a really interesting thing
that's going with these distorted letter
forms digging across the space let's
just mark it up really fast because
that's as much time as I'm gonna be able
to spend on these so let me switch my
color so you guys can see okay so we're
gonna do about another 10 to 12 minutes
yeah well I'm gonna go fast so you're
looking at your layout here and what's
happening here we're essentially cutting
the page and a half create even spaces
here and here and we ready no better not
to do that right so if you start off
with a really good element then you know
it's gonna work and then you can go
crazy with the experimentation so be
very mindful of how you're dividing the
space I like all this crazy bendy weird
warp e-type it's very hard to read very
expressive but I like it there's some
issues with the overall layout
composition problem we really talked
about this one from yin and talked about
these Joshua Gilly I think you have
something really cool here with this
type that feels like it's on a banner or
a ribbon I think it's pretty neat I
think where the rest of this layout
suffers is are things like these boxes
if you have a focal point let it be the
star remember our eye is going to go to
the point of greatest contrast so just
by doing that I think everything else
has takes the second seat - this word
resonate and I think of anything we've
learned we want to make this type a
little bit smaller it's just a little
bit too big there's oh it's it's kind of
hard to work on a layout like this
because what you see is not what you get
okay so something like that maybe and it
probably needs something down here I'm
not quite sure just yet what what we
need to add to we already talked about
that layout talked about that one this
one for
eun-young joy again I think the same
person yeah I think this was really neat
I love this layout it feels like there's
a hole in the ground these letters have
been chiseled out of granite or
something I like it a lot
maybe a little bit more contrast could
could help us a little bit here
maybe the darker areas of this could be
a little bit darker but I like it it's
really nice layout and I like all the
little bits of typography that you've
added so where you didn't want to add
extra typography but you knew you need
an element you added lines and I think
it's it's really well done okay yunji
jong i like this layout a lot the the
part that I don't like is putting the
type on this path I think for as many
weeks as we're going to talk about this
I'm going to tell you guys not to do
that and you'll continue to do it but
that's that's okay
everything else about it I think is
really nice use of line separating
grouping things together reversing this
thing out right here I think this looks
really smart very clean I like the use
of the textures maybe on this texture
here let's see if I can adjust it I
don't know if it has to go all the way
off to the edge I think it's going to be
more powerful if you pull it in and
allow our i2 to travel from the top half
to the bottom half I think one other
thing that you've seen us do quite a lot
and I'm gonna do it again and see if it
works
not always but let me try rotate it 90
degrees make it a lot smaller and just
to see if we adding a little bit of type
in here
I like that maybe like this maybe I
don't know I'm not feeling it now I
thought maybe something there could
activate this upper left corner again I
don't think we need to make this bleed
off the page it's probably better than
it not bleed off whose some interesting
okay
and the last thing is
I'm gonna see if I can delete this I
don't think you need that personally we
got some proportion issues here not
quite sure what to do with this just yet
all right I don't know if I made any
better just pointing out some things
that would change or continue to work on
this is a layout from Nia Morales
beautiful layout I like this layout a
lot
I like the crosses that you've added and
the patterns inside the cross with
different size polka dots and I think
that's really cool the one area here
that I just don't love is this 8 so I'm
gonna select this 8 I'm just going to
delete it why don't I like it I don't
like it because it's just dipping below
here and you're adding more complexity
to this area then then you need there's
already a lot going on and just in this
one area in the center we've got three
sized elements the Journal for graphic
design resin and then eight is even
bigger let's just eliminate one of those
things I don't think we need all that
stuff and then let's just add it back
here okay and if you like that kind of
separation you can shoot it out over
here
I think the baseline should carry us
across and it should be okay and if
that's too far bring it back something
to play around with but I thought the
original design was actually very nice I
wouldn't change too much about it let's
see here this is from Christiansen this
is a wild layout there's a lot going on
here
I like the texture that you've added it
looks like you took a sponge and put a
little white paint on it dabbled it on
there I think it gets a little dense in
here and for it for I don't know maybe
we need to take away one of these
elements there's a lot that's going on
there sometimes we can get carried away
with the texturing and I think having a
simple more legible element on top of
this would be all that you need okay
really nice layout
I think reduce some of this some of the
complexity here yeah I don't think I can
edit this let me try and see if I can
delete one of these elements no that's
all together yeah I can't okay
nice layout all right we talked about
that one already
I got to talk about this this is from
King win this is one where we get
experimental but we can still read every
single thing and I like that part of
this layout a lot of shapes things are
exploding asymmetry I think there's a
lot of dynamic vibes going on here
I think perhaps this is too open for my
taste
this is the one time that I think it's
good to use a paragraph box which he did
which I'm fully in love with because
then it allows me to change it really
fast and that's the time on what you
want to use that want to change
proportions I don't think you need to
fill the whole page okay and if you want
to fill the whole page the way I would
do it is to take something like this and
really open up the letting like that and
bring it in and just let some of it hit
things randomly I think I want it to
live something like that so to live on
top of the bar here and touches the G so
I would probably move that cheat down
just a little bit there okay I think it
was a good layout to begin with and I'm
just making some little tweaks here and
there all right good job King Patrick
this is in the spirits of Oh dramatic
and TC I love it it's beautiful I think
this is one of those things where let's
try in the original intent of the
inspiration
let's try and we crop it a little bit
what happens whatever cropped it so when
you have really good elements to work
with it's almost like it's impossible to
to mess it up I mean I might mess it up
but let's see wonder if we just slid it
around a little bit if we get some other
kind of vibes and some different energy
there so that would be my recommendation
it's just try to take it rotate and crop
it a little bit so that you add a little
of that visual tension this is how you
do the rotation stuff guys you get the
layout to be really good straight and
then you just crop it and rotate it all
right that's my suggestion for that one
Lars
really interesting
I don't know how you did this is crazy
that you did this all in Illustrator I
think or in Photoshop I don't know how
you did it but the type is breaking
through and we get to see the artist
beneath it so this one has some
conceptual element to it unfortunately
the other typography here it needs a
little bit of work it feels like you put
all your energy making this and we need
to make this interesting drawing this
down I'm not sure what it's doing for
your layout there's nothing else for it
to tie to or relate to so I'm gonna
start to delete some of these things I
don't know if it's doing anything for
you delete that and then now we just
look yeah yes how do you know these
elements oops let me do that for real
this time
is that interesting by itself not really
right and that's how you know it's like
that's how you know those elements need
a little bit more love that the spacing
between this is too far it's not
creating an interesting dynamic
relationship between these things so
let's work on that Lars another element
are another layout from Lara's here I
think this is really interesting
whatever you're doing with these boxes
creating this kind of op art optical
illusion thing it's a hallway it's a
pyramid I don't know what it is it's
really cool you put the white type on
top you've picked something that's nice
big and bold and chunky so I could still
read it
I think that's working well for you I
think the problem I have right now is
how do you bring some of these things
together so it doesn't feel like this is
one poster here and then this L shape is
a different poster let's figure out how
to do that okay okay this is from Cole
Fraser sorry I'm going to mile-a-minute
here I wish I could spin a little bit
more time but we're kind of at the end
of the broadcast
very simple nice layout these lines
create a certain rhythm across the page
it goes down up down that's the kind of
rhythm that you want let me just get my
brush pen back out here and switch to
ink color yeah let's do this again so
he's going up and he's going back down
that's the kind of flow that you guys
want it's a lazy s that's kind of a vibe
okay and we don't need to make
everything crazy to make it interesting
I think the the area that I would try to
work on here is this type is maybe to
let it out and maybe it's too light so
I'm going to try to make it not thin but
maybe both no that's too much
let's go light and then not to track
everything out so far
so I'm gonna scoot this up a little bit
because I want it to be anchored to this
line that's what the line is there for
alright and then I'm gonna do the same
with these I'm gonna use the eyedropper
this time so it doesn't take me as long
knock this up so those of you guys that
really have fun with opening up the
tracking it creates this really it airs
out the type a little bit too much for
me that's just my personal opinion so
I'm gonna get rid of that and then
normally I would not recommend that you
guys do this but I'm gonna try it right
now cuz you know dangers we're cooking
with gas
I'm gonna close up the letting hit
command shift are to make it justified
right and then bring it down to try to
line it up with that okay and maybe make
these bold take these two and go bold
mark I can't read the questions or
anything if there's any questions that I
need to answer it let me know okay yep
well just a small comment about this one
I think Cole let that one in from week
six but we're still getting a learning
experience right yeah I ducked early and
I'm like hey I want to talk about this
because I just saw crazy crazy crazy
layouts and we just needed to pull some
back in okay all right from Jing Wang I
like the use of the texture the
bull-type and this line here this is the
area that we need to work on we've we've
done this enough you guys activate this
space let's let's try what can we do
let's take this I'm gonna rotate it like
pretend those
those things matched up sort of right we
have this wonderful space up here let's
use it we have a little something here
and I feel like I want to add maybe a
line or something maybe something like
this and like that so I'm gonna flip
that over and then do something down
here to bring it down bring our eye down
here but I want to make this a lot
thicker something I don't think it's
perfect it's not quite right but trying
to tie those elements together I think
this area still needs a little bit of
love a little bit of work here what if I
rotate it as well and generally speaking
I would discourage you from putting a
box around something unless you were
trying to contain that entire group
because everything else is too hard to
read but in this case there's still a
lot of negative space so one thing I'm
going to suggest that you do is just
open up the container so that air light
that volume can move in I could rotate
it this way
now if I wanted to so it looks like some
kind of label and then these things
don't have to be even either you could
break it up like that
I need to move this out of the way so
this could probably be the element that
it's up there move it up here maybe
offset that a little bit guys none of
this design is premeditated I'm just
moving stuff around I don't know if it's
any good some people are saying they
need two hours to make these decisions
that you're doing two seconds you know
sometimes the constraint of time really
helps you because I'm moving fast I
don't have the luxury of sitting there
and laboring over the layout there's
something that's not working for me here
just delete this well speak you know
time we're just about up Chris okay look
a finished man Wow every layout that we
wanted to talk about see how that works
mark
okay let me let me get out of this not
to share okay I want to thank everybody
especially the students who have
enrolled in this class you've helped to
make the typography course one our most
successful courses ever to date I think
we've sold more than four hundred thirty
thousand dollars worth of courses and
remember way back in the day when the
course was like fifty nine or forty nine
dollars before it became the way it is
right now so having done this with
Milkha's giving me a lot of ideas I'm
gonna go back to the the nothing bored
but I'm gonna go back and write some new
modules and add it to the course right
now the course that you've already
enrolled in so I want to thank everybody
who's done this mark and Jonah for doing
this and especially a big giant
heartfelt thank you to Milka for sharing
her expertise wisdom and her design
energy and the way she talks about tight
that's it for me guys I hope you guys
enjoyed this whole series go back and
watch it in this week I have a surprise
oh you have a surprise a surprise okay
let's do this really fast so everybody
that has submitted a design is entered
in a drawing and for this drawing we're
gonna select three people and they each
get a course within our hundred dollar
prize limit so we're just gonna do this
really fast since we're in a hurry
hopefully you guys can hear that yeah
okay first winner is Oh
[Music]
number two number two can you guys hear
this out yeah
wow this is neat oh look two regulars
right and number three please be gentle
please be Joe yinz okay Oh beautiful
relations guys Congrats guys
we'll reach out to you guys directly yes
look I'm feeling a generous mood let's
just up the limit to three hundred
dollars of course make this three
hundred dollars or less just let us know
we'll give it to you okay
okay that's it guys I'm tired thanks for
joining us on topography Tuesday's Jonah
get us out of this hole sequence this
nightmare world oh yeah or you can sing
or something
thanks guys thanks for tuning I have
been muted you need me to love the music
myself